this is a direct from the [ __ ]
Russian he even came out from the back I
got this in 7:15 this morning like
normal people shop for reefer greetings
from podcast Ville the Churchill what's
happening now is brought to you by blue
apron blue apron is the leading meal kit
delivery service in the US while many
people know what we do many don't know
what types of meals you eat when you
cook with blue apron like quick bucatini
with broccoli and pecorino cheese an
Italian style shrimp sweet pepper with
incredible ingredients and chef designed
recipe blue apron lets you see what the
power of food can do this is what I'm
gonna do it right there blue apron we're
gonna hook up the church family with
dirty dollars off your first order if
you visit blue apron calm slash Joe
again
$30 off your first dollar check out this
week's menu and get $30 off blue apron
calm slash Joey blue apron a better way
to cook this show is also brought to you
by me undies listen you want to look
good you want to look clean you when
your undies to feel tight you know you
want to show you complain you don't have
a girlfriend but you show up with cotton
Whitey's with skid marks that's not
gonna work out no more that's not gonna
work guys you see I'm saying so this is
what I'm gonna do for you me and this is
the most comfortable boat and fun
underwear you and your significant other
will ever own
they're made from the softest materials
on earth we're talking three times
softer than cotton the solved you follow
me plus they come 100% satisfaction
guarantee me on these guarantees you you
and your significant other how about
that one you're gonna love your little
matching pairs or your money back
roomy undies has an exclusive right now
you're gonna get 20% off free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guaranteed go to
me on these doc tom slash Joey that's me
on these dot-com slash Joey you're gonna
love how they feel you're gonna love how
they fit and you're gonna love how they
look and remember you want confidence
it starts from the inside on all right
kick that [ __ ] melee presence are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what that's when
that's when it was starting now that's
that's a couple of white dudes go for
that vanilla ice are you [ __ ] kidding
me or what I don't think I've seen
somebody have that much fun with third
base since 1991 yeah no [ __ ] got into
that that I am well I [ __ ] found that
the other night I just take it I take
like you know the Goldman Goldman uh-huh
and the [ __ ] melatonin mixed it oh
yeah I did the mellah town and I do the
whole thing that's gomu gomu I don't
know why that is it to me and I did all
right and I pop them and I'm waiting an
hour for the ship to sink in and I'm
popping through videos and I found that
and I gotta tell you sir for a minute
like my body just froze I forgot about
that sound like it took me right back to
Bowser I was in a halfway house we used
to watch that the community wow him
saying oh yeah and white guys would be
there it's a couple black guys would be
dead did they not let you watch like
intense like act like explicit music did
they let you listen to that no because
in those days I'm TV was in the whole
three three floor the halfway house and
they had a community room but a TV that
you could get your food and go down
there and chitchat with all the other
convicts or they had a TV in your own
room and you were either in a three man
room or a seven-man room okay ganja you
follow me so I feel like that was a pop
pop goes the public louisa was like a
year two before there's a weird era of
hip hop with like the white dudes like a
OMC how bizarre I think he was just
bizarre
[Laughter]
so many funny songs looking back but
yeah third base I think they took
themselves pretty seriously that's my
favorite part of like when I just
watched that video was them them I love
it like there's no way that that song is
less corny than Ice Ice Baby
but they just they're just shitty
non-urbanized haha I was living in
Baldwin Ice Ice Baby came out and I hung
out with this dude that was solid I
loved him he's my brother for yes and he
had a nephew brother-in-law okay that
was probably 15
no eyes came out yeah and he was a
vanilla ice freak oh yeah
and our job was to torment them like we
were just [ __ ] it we would just who
gave you this how I'm like listen
[ __ ] uh you know what's a black dude
with the baggy pants Oh MC Hammer yeah
we go listen hammer yeah [ __ ] up
Vanilla Ice and like he would pull his
hairs out he cut his own skin I was I
was junior high Ice Ice Baby came out
and I thought I literally thought was
the best song I'd ever heard of my life
I knew how I could do the dance that was
like that was like Run DMC tough in the
lever I got I got and then Fat Boys I
was one of the rare people who had a Fat
Boys cassette remember the song jelly
roll it's like one of the worst eat I
need it jelly roll well it's good for
the heart the body and soul he did I
need it like this corny ass yes it was
terrible really well but I thought it
was the coolest I remember playing
laughs boy if you're 12 and third time I
ever heard and you know you're like that
this is the coolest and you listen to a
new step steamed and you [ __ ] throw
down boy
oh yeah you got give it to mom give the
give this to blind kids oh [ __ ] they
don't know and what a weird era where
it's like you know nwaz debut album
wasn't far behind is right around there
an iced tea with like body counts
tonight so there was like hard-hitting
real [ __ ]
at the same time as i eated I needed
generally a role listen this one was
right around the corner oh yeah that was
the worst that's one of the first CDs
everybody's crazy when you look at it
and you saw the whole thing and I really
surround New York I was a kid oh yeah
have a little [ __ ] man so I saw the
disco go from disco to [ __ ] like
Sugar Hill Gang and all that kind of I
still remember doing an Eightball one
night when I was 16
yeah what we listened to that a hip hop
bit oh yeah yes into that over and over
from 11 o'clock til 6 and the [ __ ]
it's the only album we had in the house
that's all we listened to fairly cool J
like when he was like 16 he didn't come
out too far after or like a
be five or something Eddie for that by
that time I was gone welfare was mugging
people not to change the subject Joey
but how many people have you sent to
like mental institutions I can't believe
he said this guy was cutting himself
explain something I was thinking as I
was telling Dan Cummings I had the
weirdest thing happened to me for years
people trusted me with a kidney I don't
know what the [ __ ] thing was and I'm
great the kids I'm great with kids Josh
wolf Kidal testified with Josh wolf
Italian there's not a weird subject you
go into after sending people to mental
institutions elated well but this was
the deal i I kind of babysat him and his
his uh his mom would work at Albertsons
and they knew I was struggling and they
were struggling so we would help each
other out so the struggle was they would
let me take our Atlanta to go to a gig
if I would watch no this is look how
give me a kick oh this is really open
like this okay Denver and I would watch
their kids and they had a five-year-old
kid and I loved him like he was my
[ __ ] son and I would get Chinese food
and we would watch movies and he would
ask his mother please let uncle Joey
watch so he started getting older he
liked football so we would play football
on the [ __ ] I'm cleaning out the living
room and we would play [ __ ] football
I watched that kid for years and he
hated he would always carry the ball out
so right before he's gone I just take
the ball of his hand and I go fumble and
he go you cheated you cheated this is
constantly so he would [ __ ] go to the
room and go [ __ ] you yeah I don't ever
want to play with you again but the next
day would be outside
tackle each other right and when they
were playing football I'm not about to
tell you I had to be in my [ __ ] 28 is
something he still calls me uncle Joey I
just talk to him when I was in bed baby
tutor but growing up it was a baby that
was a little younger but he was he loved
me and I loved him
and then I moved to Seattle and moved to
Los Angeles and Josh wolf just had a kid
and she had a work and Josh had a
[ __ ] work and I slept on Josh's couch
he would say listen hyung wants the
[ __ ] kids yeah hello has spoiled a
[ __ ] deal and I still remember me
being at the Comedy Store one night and
getting a call from one of my friends
saying hey man have a problem over here
I'm watching Josh's kids kid and he
won't stop [ __ ] crying Josh I called
Josh but he's too far away with his wife
can you come over yeah I had to drive
over to the hair and like they were
watching TV and playing like baby music
you didn't like that yeah how I put him
to bed yeah yeah and sub-line yeah yeah
that's with him to subline yeah and dog
within two minutes Joshua you interview
Josh wolf he'll still tell you from
today because Malia his wife were a
bigger woman and she had big [ __ ]
jugs of debt and she was warm blooded
Thai and Swedish okay so she was bigger
and I think at that time I was a bigger
guy and I don't know what it was he
loved me Jacob till this day yeah I'm
his uncle John oh yeah yeah yeah and the
girl too
yeah because the girl at that time had
to be three so she had a brother that
was fine that would tormenta and every
time I catch him [ __ ] tormenting them
I would [ __ ] tell Josh like squeezes
here yeah yes I poked him in the side
I'd do something don't but I had him all
like when I would I had them all like
after they thought they'd go buy ax and
so have you fought about Josh's kids
they would go by ax even saying like the
little one the grass still calls me
uncle John and I still in love the being
in the car with her and Josh one day and
she was in the car seat and she was the
cutest little thing and we're driving on
Vista between sunset and what's the
street and you could drive on when
you're drunk yeah fine it's Kennison
said that you could drive on fountain
when you're drunk on LY years ago and so
we're driving down that Street there's a
hole
this guy and he's walking across at a
cart but he's taking his time and he
looks at Josh wolf and Josh wolf has to
actually break the car and the guy looks
at Josh Lawson Josh goes under his
breath he goes [ __ ] you I lost in this
silence of the car and little girl goes
I can't wait though I can grow up and
say [ __ ] cuz [ __ ] it now you know she
was always around me sure sure
we tried the controller but I was always
up for some people some reason the
weirdest people trusted me with their
kids the reason one we got good energy
got good energy
I feel like this is gonna be a dark
story which to end with like you don't
know no no no yeah but I would [ __ ] with
them yeah I'd [ __ ] with them you got a
toilet [ __ ] my kids or not they'll
torment you
yeah you got a Tormentum from time to
time what do you mean like torture them
like you know please get out of my son
my son he's jumpy
he's twitchy it's just the best reaction
so rewarding we're just like you sneak
up on him when he's like nervous in like
a dark area and I'll just get right
behind ya I just really like it just got
like it the Harry Potter
oh yeah well so she just she's fine yeah
just got into it shower in the wizard
hat huh [ __ ] you scared the hell out of
her
so no so I'm not gonna get like a
costume like I do with the be the wake
up it's a good guy if you want to scare
you should get - didn't tell you this
but we should get Dementors like in one
of the books Caroline guards the gate
the guard the prison yes I think she's
only watching the first one but no yeah
the reason why I was thinking the Josh
bull for these memories cuz we were
talking before the podcast right about
see yeah yeah yeah yeah he started okay
I started in Spokane but uh Spokane
didn't have much of a scene as the best
place to start looking I didn't know
anything about stand-up when I when I
got it was one room in Spokane that was
owned by a karate guy Chris Warren the
brick wall come to the holy [ __ ] there
you go holy [ __ ] you slept in the karate
school
I miss yet I heard about that that was
bad cop whoa you slept at the karate
school I did it one on the math yeah and
I'm like come on there man that guy's
had a crazy come on
well when I started Chris had his room
in the valley and Spokane and then like
but you had to be like out of town or
somebody had to work with him for the
most part he would host he will book out
of town feature he look out of town
headliner but there was another room key
stubs out of Utah yeah it had a little
room at the Red Lion called laughs that
he stole from Tribble yeah sure he said
he sure he did yeah BZ and when they
started but he wasn't booking out of
town features so there was about ten
dudes doing comedy in Spokane but they
only booked headliners and then they
were trying to do four shows when I
started and so they just need a bodies
and so if you would just go up and just
[ __ ] talk and kill time and not make
the crowd hate you you could get stage
time immediately in front of a paid
audience so like my second week of
comedy I was doing like 10 minutes sets
in front of a paid audience well and I
didn't know that was not normal because
I didn't I didn't study stand-up I just
kind of like was trying it on a whim and
so looking back it was that so I started
getting stayed time every single weekend
because I would just at least try stuff
and then trip they recommend me he's
Tribble and that's before I got to
Seattle Seattle was like a year in for
me when I went did the underground I
hosted sucked on some couches hosted and
it was like I felt like a real comic for
the first time before that I would do
Tribble runs these these shitty [ __ ]
bars and stuff from Montana and Idaho
and Northern Nevada and Oregon and
Washington cuz I had a Honda Elantra
that ran well and that was all the all I
need is all you people headliners will
fly into Spokane I'll pick them up and
as long as I would just drive everybody
to these gigs and he's this [ __ ] was
like you'd have to the joke with a
Tribble run was you'd have to cut your
set early to start driving to make it to
the next show on time like there was so
spread outs you being like ours yeah for
real like you being nine hours and this
dude on Daddy's it was six hours some
days it was jam like one day you'd have
like a two-hour drive you're like whoa
thank God for two yeah it'll be Missoula
Montana one night and you might have to
go to Idaho Falls Idaho the next we'll
show ya would be like eight hours away
and sometimes I remember this little
tiny Hans I bald tires
going over those passes not not being
afraid of dying which I should have been
just you know but just like I should I
hope I make it to this gig again what
would possess you know what a young man
i way no no yeah no yeah yeah you know I
had logic at that time I wasn't the
smartest guy in the world right but I
remember doing dribble runs you know
right now like right now was the East
Coast yeah that tell ya home they
canceled a thousand [ __ ] a thousand I
rights and all the other oh you still
make it to the judo yep
and as always my mother called and she
said luckily we got snow ties when I
guess we got weed we got a radio and we
got an extra time in the back and I got
triple-a we're going yep
and they never miss a gig you got there
an hour late yeah it was one gig that I
was questionable they cancelled it was
that guy and it was a door it was
outside a port okay yeah very slippery
Vancouver probably along with you yeah
really slippery yeah there was like a
Saturday night gig the Sun - yeah they
got slippery but Longview Washington I
mean think about it what made you you
know your comics hit [ __ ] deer on
those Tribble right yeah the scare I
hate anything new you know I said
trouble [ __ ] hate hitting deer as if
some people like mine they would have
warnings like in those days you got to
trouble sheep right oh yeah the rundown
they would fashion like that and it
would say Tuesday March 6th would be
like that little Ogden Utah was my first
run and then my second night was River
something Wyoming where the Mafia had
taken the federal government had a take
home Sheridan of Sheridan or I forget I
arrived you somehow late Rock yes yes
that's they did it on 60 minutes do this
is a think about that the Mafia would
take the prostitutes from there yes yes
yes yes run them through their rehab
them they had strip clubs that 20 like
you were like you can't be [ __ ]
serious like it was like $5
lap dance that came with a [ __ ] a
finger up your ass like it was and it
was everywhere so the the federal
government had to get it Rock City
around me rosco me I
one time that was they had to comedy
rooms in there like a disco that turned
into a ladies night and whatever and
then you the guys you have no idea like
if I sit here with you like I you know I
[ __ ] around with Lee and I torment them
this is to do these triple runs and to
think you gonna like I would book these
in January the first triple when I
booked yeah was uh was a federal guard
spring socks bras yeah well with her the
first triple runner had booked with
January thirtieth and he called me Lee
he called me like on a Sunday night at
11:30 I'm in paging me and me seem to
like the zip code and going oh my god
out of Vancouver Washington oh my god
and running to the payphone and going
yes mr. trip Joey I've heard good things
and we're ready to go to work and you're
on the other side of the phone yeah yeah
hey I got three weeks of work for you
grab a pen and you only do you have a
pen in your leg huh yeah yeah I'm gonna
pay phone and he's like do you have a
fax number you're like not really but
I'll get back to you but yeah I'm you
feel like so oh yeah it it's a badge of
honor when just they're not crazy now
this was like your big chance to go on a
[ __ ] triple run to the national name
you're a professional you getting 75
hours in yeah you get 50 that night and
the rest day melty and a [ __ ] check
okay so that's how it is and he said he
tell you the first week you're gonna go
to Ogden Utah a try Springs and then
you're gonna end up and [ __ ] the Air
Force Base in hi-de-ho Mountain Home
Mountain Home Air Force Base and see you
it's like saying you're gonna do the
world war theater or something so we're
Matt Paoli get between you and I at that
level at that point in my life
it was like doing Madison Square Garden
and being from New York City
wow I can imagine I still remember
packing that car like going I cannot
believe this you get a free hotel hotel
room sometimes get sometimes get a free
meal you know what the best thing about
it is nobody knows what a [ __ ] I am
nobody get a hold of me I don't want
nobody to get ahold of me I don't want
nobody to know where the [ __ ] I am
it's over yeah I'm
coming a comedian that's my equivalent
of becoming Clarice would like an alone
guy yeah man just listen disappear into
the man with no name you don't know
where you're going you don't know how
you're gonna get there you got four
tires they're brand new
you just got your car tuned up you got
three hundred and ten dollars in the
bank truck you got an apartment that
sucks dick you know and one day you go
you know what I'm giving up this drug an
apartment did you do you remember this
gig in Lewiston Idaho where there was a
car that was in this bar like a sports
bar in the stage was just a little prop
stage and coming out of the car there's
like a Thunderdome everybody's above you
it was like a Wednesday night remember
going to Lewiston I got arrested in I
got had a warrant and Idaho talking a
long time got what's the they had it was
Idaho City yeah that one the little tree
in and Idaho thought was a slough Idaho
Falls too [ __ ] nightmare so it was a
Thursday and Wednesday right in there we
go Pocatello was another one Pocatello
with the other guy that brand the
business he was his partner yeah
something I and he booked Northern
California those nights Lee was very
special I mean because there was 75 with
no hotel those were very specially those
those gig tomorrow boy I saw this is the
only time I've ever seen in all the
years since - I saw somebody I watched
their comedy career end like I saw the
moment when they stopped yeah it's like
like were they left like this this crowd
is so rough this is it when a Chi
Washington I watched this guy it was
some prop guy he would do they'll even
do a half hour then you would do an hour
if you were closing the room so he's
gonna have her I'm doing an hour at this
time and the he literally gets no laughs
for a full half-hour but it was a rough
room it's not like it was easy to get
laughs but it really shook him like it
really shook him and then the next night
Wesley Sneijder I'll never forget this
he's doing his set it's a full room but
it's a it's like people would come to
some of these rooms to watch you fail
home as opposed to enjoy the show right
there looking so this guy I've never
seen this since he does about seven
minutes and he had this little suitcase
full of props oh no he just stops
talking mid-sentence he
looks around like just defeated in his
eyes and he just carefully puts all his
problems back in the suitcase and he
closes it and he walks off stage and he
walks out of the hotel never to be
[ __ ] seen again he would call freeze
check nope nobody's like triple calls me
I call tripled he's like can you do the
rest of the show and I was like can I
get his check and he was like yeah and I
was like [ __ ] done when I went did an
80-minute set I only saw one guy
fracture on stage never come back
fracture you never forget it when you
see that you like when you see her break
you [ __ ] die it was it took this kid
18 months oh I do I saw him every night
for 18 months and he saw the moment it
ended I saw two kids crack I saw one guy
[Laughter]
disappear into the impress
okichi he would come on every Monday and
go this is my impersonation of a door
this is my impersonation of a flat one
this is my band this is constantly
everything I wanted to quit of a bond
but he had his moments he had his
moments like Andy Kaufman s cancer right
yes and he was a nice sweetheart of a
guy he had a clean soul he didn't do
drugs it wasn't like a mental health
issue this was the style of calmly that
he went and he pulled me aside one day
after 9 months of me knowing him and he
goes can I ask you a question what do
you think I should do and I know
stop did impression no I would he had
something to him ok ok he Jenna he was
at a point where he was so ahead of
himself stage prepared you would write a
joke that me and you only think it's
funny oh yeah yeah yeah but then you
give up on it and then three years later
you bring it back and now that jokes are
[ __ ] oh yeah it becomes a closer
because you yeah you're ready for it
you're ready for it yeah he did he did
not know how to do this he wasn't ready
for his material telling you I wouldn't
look you guys in the face and tell you
he sucked no it sucked and he was
handsome which made it better he
big guy well this is at least that makes
the story less sad he had yet some other
films gold friends yeah yeah but he just
didn't know how to sell this is my
impersonation of the frame you know and
you know same way and he kept doing it
doing it and everywhere we go he would
bomb and he would [ __ ] they would
throw [ __ ] at him he went to like
Bellingham he went to like a no
development Castle no he didn't go to
your f---ing castle he went to the Navy
Yard then he went to parameter they'd
remember Lowe's the name the Navy just a
bit like though we live in submarines we
came up oxygen we got to put up with
impersonations over the presentation of
a submarine they drew some Adam that's
what I saw but they really did talk to
that actually I saw the broad that we
were talking about the woman that she
walked the room oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
the girl I don't do oh yes yeah Cathy
Cathy yes okay oh she's fine she's
walking right Bremerton Ellen the Navy
they were very different than that she
was the underground cop that was not her
crowd no no she wasn't there like an
abortion joke and them the end of the
story BAM they ran out of that place
so he bombs he ate a bag of dicks there
and then Pat Wolfson put him at the army
base on a Friday as an opener and he
died there and then he came back to the
open man yeah and he was [ __ ] just he
was a day away from hanging himself
right like I could see that his day job
was getting rough on him him his
girlfriend we're having prom because he
was out every night yeah and one night
he's up on the stage on a Monday he's
like good evening this is my personation
of a book you know this is my
impersonation of an eyeball this is my
impersonation of a flower the awesome
here so he go do an impersonation of a
comic right you can hear it from the
back of the room physically emotionally
like that was it you can see the easiest
so leave his body he he didn't even get
the light huh he just said good night he
walked out there
hi-five never seen again never saw uh
then there was a kid who came with a it
used to come on with a [ __ ] with a
Open Mic scenes for anybody doesn't know
this is considering comedy and think
that we're crazy your first year you're
gonna be doing comedy with 20 people in
the room and 10 of them are borderline
mental health issues and Lee is starting
to see it now that 50% of us a little
Wagga douche so at first you ask it's
enough like why am I doing this but then
somebody sees me like then you're pretty
funny come up to Seattle and then you
see how it is then you go okay know how
I put it into perspective you're rain
judgmental and then by going to the open
mikes you learn other people that want
to be Hollywood stars and you learn of
the people that are hobbyist right
there's nothing wrong with that isn't
right getting on stage
twice a week yeah yeah yeah a working
man and just having a great time yep and
I'm your week off
yeah week with Dan Cummings and opens
from right make a little money yes every
part of seeing other doing the same ten
years later but that's what they want to
do they doesn't want to be part of the
same fine yeah meet so many different uh
different people oh yeah it's such a
journey like man telling you about it's
twenty years ago and I still remember
going to the a ball in the first time
I'm Great Falls Montana crap
dammit that room was a [ __ ] nicer
it's for me it's tough going in there
with a white dude I decide to go in
there to co-headline with Rico the black
dude with the spider in his face we go
into a white diamond there isn't a black
man within a thousand [ __ ] million
yards well isn't this [ __ ]
doesn't the restaurant he's Muslim so he
gets on his hands and knees and start
playing this is without a yes is one no
no no no you didn't know nothing this is
1990 [ __ ] five okay when my heart was
praying at one of my Idaho you know I've
never heard nothin gonna around Idaho
with minorities better I'm sitting on I
can't believe I'm gonna [ __ ] diner
filled with white people and ruther and
I'm with a six foot six three hundred
and twenty pound black man who's on the
floor plan how are
now did he do that after like you guys
were already sitting together like yeah
like I didn't know when the bullet was
gonna come to my [ __ ] head got hella
back to that bar yeah and the dog girl
look like a G but she was the owner's
daughter so she's very sweet she's very
nice I'm very polite I'm working with a
female what co-headlined she does that
that's the thing you need let me know
when I go well to be honest for you I'm
gonna trouble run then there's gonna be
a long week if I get some marijuana it
would be tremendous she goes is that all
you need and then Bob while I was do you
have and she goes name it we have a
Mexican cook in the back and he's got 20
cousins and part of an organization up
here so you need rollerskates
you need bubblegum you need cocaine
laced [ __ ] bazookas I mean she
stocked this up for the week pause where
it got crazy she was a sweet girl
beautiful girl you know the whole thing
yeah she goes out deliver it to your
hotel room right she gonna there she's
like I'll take a blast like I tried to
get my 20 bucks I'm like a little [ __ ]
cuz no no that's okay
I'll take it do you mind if I do it
tasty and I said yeah do whatever you
want
yeah this [ __ ] pulled out of Riggs and
naturally I was like when does it end up
like you shootin cocaine in [ __ ]
God's Country what are you a Richmond
right she took the rig out or something
I can't see needles so I'm gonna go
outside
she rigged her coke shot it and [ __ ]
left and then came back and left me a
note in the door like an hour later like
I'd like to come back and shoot some
more later Wow
I found it in the morning like I did two
bumps that night with the how to drive
eight hours
oh man small towns and things like that
people reach a level of despair people
like I'm from a really small town Idaho
and and I feel like similarities in some
ways too when I hear stories of people
from like a ghetto where it's like a
land of no hope when you feel like
there's no hope it's like a lot of
people's little towns there third fourth
generation little town you know like
that and they just feel like they're
stuck there forever they want to get out
when the high school is over and then
when they don't the people who stay
it's like a deep level of despair sinks
in and you just see like the light go
out in their eyes and then it's like the
mass and then the heroin is you know
like fairly big heroin is actually big
in Coeur d'Alene where I live now like
there's a real opiate problem you know
for ski talk
it's a beautiful beautiful beautiful if
you got money if you got honey they used
to have a gig there in 95 yeah there
once a month there's a little I worked
it and the guy the only came up to me
goes I got I like he goes on from
driving etiquette but I can't have as
many [ __ ] so I'll bring you back he
gave me an extra hundred our bill and he
was a gentleman yeah yeah your ski pass
from Saturday oh yeah they kick they
don't have that anymore they say okay it
was like a special a comics uncle booked
it huh and it was once a month and I got
it like this yes I'm burned I went up
there I didn't ski right but the guy
came out on Saturdays like you know what
I just had a lot of complaints too yeah
yeah yeah like the [ __ ] but I was
telling leave Moscow Idaho oh yeah the
Vandals so now after I become a Tribble
guy my next dream do you want to
continue with boogers so I moved to
Seattle and the big book up there is
John Fox this guy had a newspaper that I
read every week called just four lives I
would sit there at night coked out
crying circling the clubs I was gonna
perform at some later punchline in San
Francisco Oh Walnut Creek I'm gonna be
there someday yeah the [ __ ] comedy
Castle and [ __ ] whatever yeah yeah
and Here I am in John Fox territory I
got up to Seattle on a Saturday I
showcased at the I did the open mic
Monday right rights day Josh wolf had a
show on Wednesday yeah
and Thursday I had a call from you John
Fox you go on a Moscow Idaho baby I'm
sad that I hit the big time if you think
Jeb was big time tribbles more potatoes
oh yeah it's yeah I'm Fox I'm hitting
the big time this is the level in your
mind oh yeah people how you like called
David like if you don't call mr. dribble
no more like they what the [ __ ] you got
from me you [ __ ] punk-ass [ __ ] I
wasn't asked about the underground are
you wanted [ __ ] cuz exactly help I know
I've met I stab these house we live in
this house Moses real
he is a nice guy of a guy one here he
knows he knows what his gigs are that's
what I've always loved about David
there's no bullshitting he knows that
he'd love it to death I should have said
that no but no but it does throw you the
first time
[ __ ] he comes up yeah I'm becoming us
how you doing he puts a sec yeah yeah
I'm David Tribble Ewing huh yeah what
the [ __ ] oh my god he's a nice sweet guy
but you know what there's a lot of he
toured he toured four years in a little
band yeah he did all the same kind of
bars and stuff for years how he learns
how about those cognitive yelps I give
him a lot of credit
hey listen it's how I learned to cut my
teeth it's how you figure it out you
know yeah I gotta tell you something the
other night back to school zone I wasn't
feeling it felt yeah see that movie
Matthew Broderick no no the other the
junkie the Iron Man Robert Downey jr.
Jesus Christ Robert Downey Julia's
decayed with the blue hair so huh Young
is the [ __ ] body
he's Dangerfield son Annette no no no he
plays the best friends the Dangerfield
okay okay the producers nephew he's even
only given 80 grand of his kid you never
saw me
right right right I never saw that guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah I could tell it was
like the kid from Karate Kid was in it
he was the really good-looking kid of
that and I'm watching this movie my wife
is in the room my daughter they leave
what the [ __ ] I'm sitting there watching
this stupid movie I'm waiting for the
business scene the business school scene
where he tells the teacher where'd you
where do we put our fantasy where do we
put our fictional business and he goes
how about fantasy land and you know and
then they I still watch the Kenaston
scene
yeah and Kennison right off the bat he's
like during the Vietnam I mean 15
television was completely different man
movies were completely goes during the
Vietnam does anybody want to explain the
Vietnam kind of like to me he's like the
girls like you know she's a sweet girl
from the valley she's like the enemy's
kind of like was a north side and he
goes that's a great answer
but no you're wrong it was it was a we
were we should have pushed a bunch of
[ __ ] rice eating patties like he just
fiat
goes off and then Rodney goes whoa whoa
she's a kid she doesn't even know I mean
I'm [ __ ] howling right now yeah and
he goes okay mr. helper you want to talk
to me about the Korean Conflict and he
[ __ ] goes well forget Amiga and I
started crawling because I still
remember being in the movie theater
watching that being a 24 year old kid a
loser frustrated watching him going I
have to be in the movie with him like I
don't know how but I'm gonna have to do
this like I wasn't thinking about stand
up stand up wasn't even him right was I
even thinking about it what that movie
come out Lee 86 or 90 80 yet stand up
wasn't I didn't come into prison yet I
haven't even gotten to prison yet stand
up wasn't even in my horizon but I kept
looking at him and that move 86 I went
by myself I went to the first movie oh
wow it came out on a Friday at 11:15 I
was there 11:15 Stone Chinese food in my
stomach ready to go like that yeah yeah
I didn't give a [ __ ] I had a ritual I
went by myself
so I don't have to hear nobody's
[ __ ] then you got there late the bus
right I know I'm prepared I got a plan
there is about it I'm serious I know
where I'm sitting
what I know the whole [ __ ] deal and I
still remember sitting in a movie
theater like frustrated like it took me
back there for a second that the
frustration I was feeling came out like
tears ran down my face like how
frustrated I was at that time in my life
but I just wanted to be in a [ __ ]
movie Nev like if I could just figure
out how to get there right like from
that seat how I could jump into that
screen walking killed me and in 19 2003
I'm beat myself around the bush I'm
auditioning for a bunch of [ __ ] and I
got a call from a casting director can
you come in it 2:30 you reading for the
new Rodney movie and I'm like what Wow
and I get down to Sunset it's across the
street from the strip club right up the
block from the Comedy Store
okay that's strip club there almost
no the other way okay up to the Comedy
Store rather on sunset across from right
now there's a building yeah where they
used to cast high level [ __ ] movies
Wow
she cast me in something before I went
there for something big before I saw
like big guys that was like ah my god
yeah what the [ __ ] like I had been to
auditions before but this is where they
often you water they valid that in your
parking there were white people these
are white people they had parking in the
back right when you went there you were
there by yourself like for a pre-read so
I went in there and I sign my name and
no [ __ ] I hear Rodney's voice in that
[ __ ] audition Wow and I'm like oh no
but when they opened the door it was a
comment from the store he oh he runs
economy he runs the Laugh Factory now in
Vegas I love like a brother I can't
think of his [ __ ] name right now I
never worked that he was direct basil
hairy basil was directing the movie and
Harry had seen me at the store right so
when I walked then I saw Harry Rodney
the casting director and somebody else
called Allan Stevens another old-school
comic that had gotten me at Harless with
[ __ ] james coburn right so yeah yeah
so now I'm hole bubbling so everybody's
I can't do enjoyed this hi I do mr.
Dangerfield I don't say nothing about I
love Melissa yeah yeah I don't even get
to that point of not almost [ __ ] passes
I didn't bring it I love your move no
one is a dick I wanted a like a tough
guy evil eyeball to look at you yo [ __ ]
and me whoa I'm coming all over myself
like I'm in the room yeah oh my god and
I read for the role I have [ __ ] I
knew it inside and out backwards I knew
that I got coached the whole thing at
the end of the audition they go bro that
was a great [ __ ] job thank you we'll
let you know run he goes no we cast that
role already but you know what they're
gonna call you I'm gonna find something
for you I swear to God and a week later
they called me I went down there and I
go what am i doing they go we don't
Rodney just at the core they wanted you
so they kept call me Coco like that
because I'm gonna call you Joe Joe so he
gave me the name of Joe Joe and he put
me in this movie with Christy Ali [ __ ]
the dude from vacation I mean it was
filled with names I mean the movie is a
yes ya Leah prime it was a beautiful the
movie was a disaster but just being
there he kept me there for [ __ ] eight
days it was the biggest paycheck I had
ever seen in my life like I've never
been on a screen yeah bill on movies for
one day
Oh day and a half tops eight days eating
with everybody huh and it was him and
they would I would you know at the end
of when you shoot they give you a
quality and they they give you a call
sheet that tells you what time you come
in the next day and what seems you're
doing they would give me a call she like
oh I'm not on the call sheet and they go
go ask Rodney and I would have to walk
to ride these trailers on that on the
door and Rodney would open his door with
his [ __ ] robot with his balls hanging
out they go what and I go my working
come on yeah yeah yeah yeah kid come
back tomorrow they you know the great
job that they closed the door so I find
that out that it was it's so weird the
journey in comedy yeah like it took me
from 1986 in my mind like in my mind
from thinking it right like that it made
me cry and it made me emotional and I
wanted to let people know that sometimes
it's just making that mental note yeah
like I wasn't invited to his funeral I
wasn't one of his close friends I wasn't
in wonder what his finals you know I'm
not gonna tell you that but he [ __ ]
pushed me into doing comedy in a way
happen Andrew yeah it is amazing like
what like when you have those little
emotional I just started having those
like recently what it's like when I
started I didn't have like a guy I
wanted to meet I just had an idea of
what I wanted to do and it's like I
always loved kind of independent
musicians I was more into music than
comedy but guys like oh like a like a
Ben Folds like a Elliott Smith like
these kind of quirky singer-songwriters
Elliott Smith was big as use from the
Newton Northwest and he moved down to LA
at the end but it's like he was just a
little rock clubs but he had diehard
fans who came to see him and I'm like
right at it
never changed in my golem like all I
wanted was that if I could fill up a
little room rock club whatever people
who just came to see me who liked you
know my said to him whatever they wanted
to be on my ride and for the first time
only a couple times but just just last
weekend I was just doing this little
Club in Minneapolis but it was like it
wasn't big actually
ya know it's just a little Sisyphus
brewings little like alt room that they
have there just two nights it's only
like a little 90 seater but it was sold
out you know and it was like and I and I
have this podcast now where people come
they wear their t-shirts and I did a
live podcast during the day and it was
like it caught me off guard but it was
like an afternoon show but it's like
people wearing the hats and the t-shirts
and in the did a little Q&A afterwards
and I and they're just some lady said
thank you for doing this whatever like
that and I almost cried like and I'm not
an emotional person you see outside but
it just like hit me where I'm like [ __ ]
this is this is where the guy I liked
Elliot's submit that's what that's what
he was doing you know like that that's
what I wanted to do when I started and
here it is and it just feels you know
you grind for so long you have some
buddies at least I have totally
self-doubt mom what's wrong like that's
never gonna [ __ ] happen but whatever
I'm gonna keep trying and then it
actually happens and for me just on that
little level it was like holy [ __ ] man
if I died right now I did this this no
one can take this from me oh you know
comedy now as a whole it'll be 18 years
this summer
Christ yeah yeah yeah I started in 2000
yeah yeah grinding tribble runs you went
and I had a weird arc where I had heat
early on like four years then I got
Montreal and then I got Comedy Central I
got a half-hour and I got an hour like
boom boom boom early but I wasn't ready
I mean and I don't regret this but I
mean people liked it but then I got a
taste of the business where back in 2010
I had a our special air but it didn't
get the ratings they wanted and I kind
of got thrown back to the woodpile and
it bout broke me I was just like [ __ ]
that was my whole plan I just my plan
was like to get the hour and then I
thought that business would just you
know unfold in front of me and then I
remember doing Grand Rapids which is
actually where my favorite clubs now but
I was in Grand Rapids Michigan
dr. grins great loved that Club closed
all my favorite rooms now it's like I
have a good grip but it's like I had
this expectation once a special came out
it'd be full and I remember doing it
that like two weeks after the thing
debuted and it was a half-empty room
still I was like [ __ ] man what I don't
know what to [ __ ] do now like and
it's like and then I just kind of like
had to kind of reinvent I just kept
putting out you know albums or whatever
and then randomly randomly for me this
new
Media for me it was just this podcast I
started doing a year ago that like all
the things I've tried all the stand-up
things all the albums I did what fans
like him but the thing that got the
people to actually come to the shows
with this little time sock podcast and
it changed but it took you know 18 years
the completion of Jesus Christ yeah it
really is the completion of a circle you
know when we tell these stories like I
just saw these face and you said 18
years I know you probably like I hate to
hear that you like [ __ ] that I get it
yeah that puts Lea at 48 right right
yeah pretty well yeah 47 in oh yeah
nobody wants to hear that I don't know
it's one of the things that oh it's a
real reality back you know but I'm 55
right
so you really have to have a real like I
asked you what possessed you
yeah who the [ __ ] is Dan Cummings like
your fault like mr. great is mr.
Cummings tall why now my dad yeah he
still life yeah yeah yeah go wouldn't
mr. Cummings go can I ask you a question
son right I love you I raised you
yeah your brother's a doctor yeah this
is a lawyer are you and we Todd right
your eyes borrowed no tires yeah made to
go to where the 75 hours yeah idiot
which mother's name Charlene Charlene
can you give you please and help me put
more on before I smack ya now you wanted
to do comedy if the brother just won an
award because he's a doctor this is the
lawyer of the year and he wants to be
funny man and a blizzard is coming yeah
don't know if a situation like yeah like
and that's what we love it
yep that's it like it's gonna be a
blackout that's fine yeah instead of
eight hours are gonna take me 16 I'm
gonna leave in 20 yeah we really believe
in my head my people will come in the
room and go me do you want me to smack
the [ __ ] out of you like you're going
where fry yeah right
we got that passion man you got that
drive you know it's really like you
think back on it and you go what what oh
yes I made me think what my with their
humming is could Charlie get into it
that's my mom [ __ ] [ __ ] family that
[ __ ] brother please
I told you the block boom my mom was so
worried because I was the first person
in my extended family on either side
from any generation go back to ever go
to college like I come from a long line
of just like laborers essentially and so
it's like there was all this kind of
pressure because I did well in school
but I didn't really care about it but I
but it's like that it was doctor lawyer
because no one in my family has ever
been something like that so it was that
or and then so when I just after you
know I got a psych degree and then I
just stopped it was my mom was like what
the [ __ ] like you know like all of her
hopes and dreams she's just watching
them being like thrown away and then you
have moments to where it's like I did
well in school and then kids who didn't
do as well but buddies of mine whatever
they're getting like corporate jobs now
and I'm on a Greyhound bus to do 150
bucks to host an Albuquerque at laughs
for Russ Revis for the weekend and you
know and sleeping on a [ __ ] couch and
there's moments to we left [ __ ] am i
doing where is Russ Revis hopefully dead
Davis was the biggest [ __ ] I ever
work God that guy that guy was a
legendary [ __ ] Russ rebus there was a
guy hippie man John Nova's head at a
Colorado you may remember him at the
Denver beautiful person very nice kind
of hippie vibe and a nice guy nice guy I
saw Russ do the meanest thing Russ would
belittle the comics that work for him
I remember he picked me up I took like
over 24 hours to get on a greyhound and
he bitched at me about half and [ __ ]
he would top this weird East Coast but
California dude dude what kind of
[ __ ] MC think she's a [ __ ] feature
needs me to pick him up the [ __ ]
Greyhound station you use [ __ ]
comedies flip he was [ __ ] he'd [ __ ]
on you all the time we care all the time
yes it could Haiti with the Gandhi yeah
Coppola on his wall and John Nova said
had a lazy eye a wandering eye and and
this is the kind of person Russ was Russ
all of a sudden is talking to him he
goes dude what the [ __ ] wrong with
your eye it's all [ __ ] up like a
[ __ ] lizard or some [ __ ] and John
chuckles yeah look he was gonna cry he
goes
Jesus Russ this
because my [ __ ] high man okay so let
me take you back hahahaha shall I of
1991 okay yeah no I'm gonna take you
back to March of 1991 I am a doorman in
the comedy club and I am the DJ okay
don't man first DJ / DJ I got promoted
cuz the decent Denver this is Denver
wit's end
oh yeah the worst club in the history of
calmly and the words neighborhood at
that time in the world I mean it was
just a dead Bart [ __ ] neighborhood
filled with dead white people dead white
people like dead like they couldn't they
weren't good enough for Denver and
Boulder than one of nobody wanted
understand I lived at Westminster this
dirty years ago there's only a mall
there that's it the mall was great cuz I
was in the halfway house and then it was
I used to work on 104th and Thor it and
the more had a [ __ ] magic store and
had those cigarette loads and you put it
the people's cigarettes so I would crack
people with those if I hated yeah a
cigarette that was the only thing was he
handsome was good for was that one match
extort them all that's it the magic
double so I'm the house [ __ ] DJ you
come to me you tell me what time you
want write music you want and then I got
promoted to the bar back well I'll at
that time some of the young comic named
Roger Beavis who was a Subaru salesman
in Colorado Springs Colorado
who was married to a beautiful blonde
woman he still made her know I think
right now a different blonde woman he's
busy okay and she was very cute he was
very handsome man Spanish kid a little
bit of potential you know I didn't know
much it's a Christmas um stage presence
yeah he had some stage presence he drove
a justy which was a three cylinder
Subaru and we became friends and when I
quit would send in fact he got me a
couple gigs hoping for okay you know
this one on for about a year I would
take gigs from Todd Jordan I would take
gigs from him
Rick currents I had like 5 headliners
and all me gigs and that was hustling so
I was breaking even ever yeah so you
know I moved to Seattle I moved to LA
like I'm gonna lay now but the
storm regular at the store and I'm
featuring El Paso okay
and somebody says to me are you friends
with Russ Rivas and I go [ __ ] yet how
you kidding me me rushes and Hicks
together and he goes call them up next
time and do that week first and then
come here
and I go that's genius yeah and he goes
as a matter of fact here's his number he
knows you're here this week so I call
roughs up and I go Russ Jodi's heels
great the ethnical Russ I'm not looking
for nothing for me I'm working over a
now El Paso he says next time I could
tie in it can you give me a features
Bonnie cuz you gotta send me a tape I go
are you [ __ ] kidding me send you a
tape I've been friends with you for
[ __ ] at that time it was 91 now it's
98 I go don't worry about a brother
thank you I hung up and then I just
heard horror story you know the large
Harbor story upon our salary and it was
ego based fund yeah I'm a headliner in
Vegas like that's exactly exactly I was
it big client you don't understand who
the [ __ ] I am
I'm a headliner at the Mirage the second
Thursday of the month okay you ever get
that was your guy named David test row
there was that guy yep yep let me tell
Monica player Greg man nice dude nice
dude I saw Russ dress him [ __ ] down
it was the one of this next to the I
comment one of the other saddest things
I saw Russ do it was the first time
anyone had sold out or the club had been
sold out he used the rock Dave
test-drove listen you hear from uncle
Joey Dave tester would break out that
harmonic yeah it would have that room oh
he was a jolly fat guy that one night he
was dead that he was the headline of the
night at the open mic when they flipped
a beer cap at me and I told the kid you
flip another [ __ ] be a cab at me we're
gonna have a problem and he flipped the
big cap at me and I said [ __ ] your
mother to come right at this stage and I
hit him in the head with the microphone
those microphones in it yeah well
everywhere he was the headliner he had a
funny hilarious so now two years later
I've done a thousand gigs of tester oh
yeah now five years later they have
worked with him in Portland yeah and
he's like he comes up to me he's like
hey you're not gonna hit nobody
microphone tonight nicest guy nice
funny you know professional he happened
he was there when like the russet opens
up some new location in Albuquerque and
it sold out that night and David all
David did was just say that he was now
this is cool man I'm happy to be here
when it's sold out somehow and Russ is
[ __ ] [ __ ] mind he takes that as
David is trying to tell him that he's
the reason he sold out and he would do
this thing he would gather it wasn't
enough for him to belittle somebody he
would gather the waitstaff to witness
the belittling and he starts going he's
like dude you will you [ __ ] think you
had something to do with this you
[ __ ] hack you [ __ ] thing get over
hey come here career he's like calling
the weights up this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] thinks he's up this is before the
show he was I was like shays it was he
was a sociopath yeah and I heard his
career as [ __ ] tanks I'm like he's
well no no he had like he healed the
club right and then he went away oh my
god and then you know he book did him
favors because he owned the yep it's all
gone now when you own a club a club
wanna go hey book my boy yeah I'll give
you a Christmas weekend here and there's
a lot of guys who've made a career out
of doing some kinky [ __ ] the business I
don't want to say no names but they've
done kinky [ __ ] and that's how they made
a business feel and I said business but
the hope for us is opening up for David
testo somewhere right now I'll be there
somewhere the Pete and Russ that whole
apps chain listen Oh Scotty Goffin and
in Tucson to Tucson the club that was
the best one was he the Santa Fe laughs
oh it was and all that one it was
Albuquerque the owner of Albuquerque
before us died in a motorcycle accident
drunk driver hit him yeah that guy was
supposed to be what was keeping laughs
alive because he was booking the last
club yeah and he was a great guy
huh they sold that one to him and then
there was there was there was
Albuquerque to Sonia and then there was
another one and then it became the one
in Colorado Springs I never worked that
one maybe yeah no I worked at whether it
was Jeff Valdez and Judy Brown was the
book Judy Brad that's right she came out
of Colorado before he does more mouths
and she would try to [ __ ] make it you
take a stand of course for you to be
able to get on stage and do the open mic
35 bucks no [ __ ] that'll be my business
what did you ever work to tri-cities oh
yeah oh my god I got nothing
what's the name of the place well now
it's a bowling alley called atomic I
used to be a red then reach to be a Red
Lion or no a double tree or is both it
was double tree it was a red line and
the name of the room was developed a
double room is that what the bar was the
bar in the hotel let me tell you
something oh you got the story you don't
love you look that when you look the
clubs of Washington State it said the
underground giggles I never forget the
first time somebody said call this lady
if you want to work the volcano room
I expected this [ __ ] grand right right
and it was just a hotel with god-awful
[ __ ] food it was like that room that
they booked not in Nyack there's a room
they booked in Lausanne the New York
City towns that you go up then it's just
a gas station the whole weekend you're
in the basement it's cold even with the
heat on you're freezing in the winter
the only o do the club in the wintertime
yeah because everybody goes to it and
you're next to a hotel Friday and
Saturday yeah yeah and you gotta take a
bus up there than a cab a $30 cab ride
to this gig and they would pay you 500
bucks for the weekend and you get only
booked me in January I would have to fly
back from here Wow
go to New York and then take a bus up
there and then in the hole I'll be
breaking even the [ __ ] what's the club
bananas bananas in earthy yes now it's
it's they say they have new owners yeah
yeah yeah now the guys in helium took it
all lilium took it over so that
interesting that's right cities one that
was the first row gig I ever did out of
outside of Spokane it was the first
painted them when I when I did it it was
a guy named Nick Tyson and key Stubbs
Nick ties - now that Spokane key Stubbs
out of uh just part of that little
short-lived laughs chain they had up
there but uh you know it switched it was
like triple before that I think what a
triple actors Chris Warren I think had
it would like juggle around Chris but
he's I don't know his mom went to prison
for some and he had some crazy family
business his mom was like British you'd
have Britta
accent and she went to embezzling or
something we heard and Chris out a bunch
of people money he got real ugly with
Chris before he left Spokane it was all
it's neither he had a his headshot was
hit with machine guns with two [ __ ]
you sure he's crazy his love he was
crazy his karate trophies but yeah but I
Bryan Callen was another guy who's in
Denver now but he was doing he was the
headliner
I was the I'll never forget this said
either I was the beach I do 30 minutes
cold I went up and I did 30 minutes to
absolute silence
I didn't get a laugh now one laugh in 30
minutes and I was just like sweat going
down your back where you just feeling
your ass crack and just did a flop sweat
and it's just like but I left stage
thinking like I well whatever it's a
small crowd yeah you know there's the
[ __ ] you know they suck cause it was the
crowd Bryan Callen goes up and murders
for an hour like he brought a life out
of these people that I didn't think was
even remotely possible and I was too
dumb at that time to know that when you
have a horrible set just [ __ ] get out
of there go hide like leave but I
thought etiquette was you stood by the
door and you thanked people with like
watching the show so I'm standing next
to Brian after this train wreck and I'll
never forget this this one dude comes up
now I'm not making this story he goes to
Brian he goes oh man he's like this
rednecky guy he's like oh man he goes
you were funny he's like man I'd love to
get you beer holy [ __ ] you were funny
man and then he sees me standing next to
him he goes and you how you should do
what he does
that's literally what he said to me you
should do what he does he doesn't even
think he's because rules above I just
died inside who do you told me that
those those little rugs up there you
realize who in that [ __ ] potato run
when you do uh the Air Force Base and
they show you not home your room is a
[ __ ] barrack I never actually did
Mount now I know my home but I never did
that room to room the size of that door
right there that's what you have that
couch huh you hang your clothes up to
have a little tiny TV and your shower
was down the [ __ ] wall why you're
like Jesus Christ what a [ __ ] is my life
going up on an Air Force Base I mean it
was just they give you food coop
to share I mean they just put you
through so many different scenarios yeah
but if you look back at it it prepares
you for this oh for sure for sure
there's nothing that can faze you
there's you so many scenarios that you
get [ __ ] with yep that it prepares you
for this [ __ ] laying around like yeah
taking this game off your shoulders oh
yeah it's weird I bumped it to slash
once in 1998 in Vegas I was opening up
for Rogen at the Riviera Jean our
guitarist busts like these little I mean
he was definitely on a whole other slash
yeah I guess yeah he was like therefore
you're comfortable the festival was foul
like he'd you know they paid him to show
I say I some junior I wasn't touring it
was 98 yeah and I did in those days I
used to see him a lot around town at
different comedy shows he would come to
the one that we did next over the room
Jay Davis had way before you know the
other night we met that kid John Alps
uh-huh I've known John Allen since 1998
I met him in that room I'm talking about
John Evans was room my manager my
manager took him with him when he was
out of this original agency and John
Adams was a TV guy you just don't
recognize him he was on TV for 12 years
he was only 2 syndicated shows because
Jeff Kaplan was one of the best managers
in the business
Jeff Gelman hated the road Jeff Gatlin
knew that if he had you it's for TV and
fun to get you on a TV show for six
years
that was his [ __ ] ball he when you
talk to Jeff about the road he gladly
won't hear about ya
I didn't want to hear about you could do
spots at the store anij in town huh and
that's what he did he made that kid one
of his example but I met that kid at the
Union it was called the Union and I saw
slash there like a couple times yeah
that's when you'd see Vince Vaughn out
at night wide open mikes when I met
embed yeah you know that swingers was
hot in you like what oh [ __ ]
and I saw him in Vegas I'll never forget
this I couldn't sleep
you know in Las Vegas I didn't really
have weed Rogan and smoked weed so I got
up and went for a walk I didn't have
money
gambled and I'm gonna be that I would
eat the employee cafeteria Lee they like
so isn't it the leftover from the fares
on oh yeah with back box of the turkey
legs yeah you like buffet we used to
have that covers you're gonna love
buffets when you work Vegas as an opener
boy when they give you that card to the
employee [ __ ] dining room take you see
cake with missing icing cuz somebody
have scrubbed their finger you know
saying that's always a real treat ain't
it
that's always a boost for you comedy
career when you they give you the old
red meat that mafia meat but you're so
[ __ ] hungry and it's free you don't
give a [ __ ] what you put in your body
and that stuff keeps you hungry so much
later because you don't want to go back
there to I think that motivates you
well how it would be fun if I could find
Kouga I didn't need it to be fun of you
will need it right if you do it [ __ ]
around two weeks ago yeah good weather
can't help but do that some yes you have
to do that yeah it would it's like we go
to the fourth wall a lot I go to an open
mind okay up to I wanna hear no boos
five minutes five dollars yeah but you
it takes you just reminds you yeah what
you see that you have what these guys
want right and how lucky you are I now
that you stuck with it these guys have
no idea yeah what they're about to walk
into every time I go to an open mic
there I count the room and in my mind I
do the math automatically out of the
eight people four of them we're gonna
quit right two of them are gonna go to
Montreal and two really gonna be
big-time stars who is it gonna be out of
the eight yeah yeah who is it gonna be
that's why I love we were talking about
the show and I know people like Kishi I
love listen yeah it feels good when
somebody comes up to you after a show
today they say hey man you have a great
show that feels [ __ ] great yeah and
it feels great when somebody comes up to
you and talks to you about the podcast
yeah that's a great feeling but you know
what feels even better there's two
things
when somebody comes up to you and says
hey man I saw you in Seattle oh yeah
and I knew that you were gonna be yeah I
get those wouldn't see ya
yeah at the Comedy Store I'll get out of
the club or some yeah and be a side and
go you remember that Club with the
parrot in the background and [ __ ]
Washington the rise to bright Wednesday
yeah I was the manager there and you
used to make me laugh back then yeah you
know that one thing I liked when people
say but the second thing I like when
people say is this you got went to see
Jim Gaffigan Rogan
right right right what does he do
Cummings on what to see Bert Kreischer
right I went to see [ __ ] cake Quigley
I went to see [ __ ] Cyrus oh man
I love when people say that yeah I
really get off when people say that
because I know you were student of the
game
yeah yeah legal on stage for the first
couple times I had my tongue Uli's gonna
be Richard Pryor but he was a lot better
than I was when I gotta stay at for his
gas times why because the last time he
is writing a student not only he's 30 so
for the last 15 years he's been watching
comedy right and listening to comedy an
average of Lee five hours a week since
you've been 15 probably yeah yeah we
always watch specials listen to CDs
that's how that's how it starts so I
never did that I never did that killing
I was a fan of [ __ ] huh Pryor like
yeah bicentennial [ __ ] yeah yeah I
know that now
yeah I was there with ya like I remember
still going to a store and getting
Bicentennial [ __ ] right right oh geez
that's the one with him it's like the
American flag kind of in the matter
right shirt off yeah yeah yeah yeah what
the [ __ ] is this and then you know
seeing David Brenner on TV there was no
doubt of it
you had an encyclopedia you know saying
and then like somebody when I was about
maybe 20 turned me on to Lenny Bruce oh
wow and I was like that's amazing and
then when I was 15 somebody turned me on
to let him eat and then what thing was
he always knew what my comics were gonna
be on yeah so no matter
yes I think it was like Wednesdays or
Thursdays or Tuesday's no matter what I
did those nights I didn't get high right
I would always have a cocktail or two
and slip by his house 11:30 and he would
bring the leftovers his mom would make
and we would watch Letterman and we
would out from Letterman was [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
let him it was a [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] back then and that spiked
my last ain't family Lenny Bruce Carlin
a little bit yeah he's my favorite but
not as much as Pryor right does I I
liked that crazy like rah motion and
everything jazz yeah that [ __ ] my mom
was I never mom was setting out live we
didn't have money sounds like so hokey
but like in Reagan's where I grew up is
so tiny Idaho town we didn't have cable
and things for a while like we didn't
have very many channels so you get like
Network channels like the big three NBC
CBS ABC but for a lot of please a house
like you'd like you weren't able to get
like they literally didn't have cable I
didn't run it to that town and so NBC 7
out live that was my comedy exposure for
the week was Washington cetera and I
would watch it with my grandma because
for most my childhood was my my mom my
dad was up in Alaska and it was I and I
was my mommy well my parents divorced
when I was young he did he went up in
construction and stuff up there and
different things and but like I would
just go to my grandma Betties and we'd
watch that live every Saturday but then
you know as I got older you grow up in a
little town like that you don't know
anybody I didn't know anybody who had a
white-collar job let alone an
entertainment you know so it seemed so
beyond fantasy that I just went to
college and like tried to get like a
quote/unquote tradition just some kind
of degree your skin.the degree was the
goal and then I did sketch comedy but I
just never thought of it again never
entertained any of that as a job
possibility like who the [ __ ] am i it's
like he just do it and then I did
stand-up was what was available when I
was just trying stuff I didn't like my
socio social work kind of career that
was I was trying to get into and I just
went and tried different things
but I'm lucky I feel like I was lucky I
didn't study comedy cuz I think I would
have been intimidated like because I
watched sketch and I saw I you know had
some idea of like what you could do I
guess comedic ly in some way on a stage
you know in some form but I didn't I
hadn't really watched much stand-up and
I think it was easier in a way where I
think about I've been worried I don't
know if you ever worry about this lead
but if you like it when you watch all
the greats is there an expectation if
you're gonna try and be great
immediately because I didn't have that I
just like okay let's just go go [ __ ]
around on stage I wasn't thinking like
about you know prior and Carlin and then
the modern you know greats and stuff
like that because I didn't know their
stuff well though I mean I think it
helped him back a little bit because
I've had people asking me I've been
working with joy for six years so yes
people have always asked and I had a
couple people say I should try it out
and I always say I'm not that kind of
funny like I would see all these amazing
I don't watch every special so I see all
these graves you're seeing it with their
prime you're not seeing them start
writing it yeah it's very different yeah
yeah do you but you now you get though
that all those guys [ __ ] sucked when
I first started like everyone goes to a
shitty periods yeah I still think it
really hasn't hit me how much how much
time it's gonna take to be honest okay
like even still in my head I'm like yeah
maybe five years but like it's just you
might though yeah everybody's path is
different you might you know what
anybody accelerate faster but it's uh
that I don't know if I want to
necessarily like I'm really enjoying
like I've been going to one I've been
going to the fourth wall and I'm just
now starting to do shows in other places
like I think about calmly and least I
know one thing about lay that this might
Tommy always opens up your horizons once
you do calmly and you jump off that clip
now you're a different person you really
are a different person so if you're
looking at me asking me do I think
reasonably up there Richard Pryor or not
yeah I don't think so I think Lee is
gonna shine yeah it's gonna take
stand-up and after a year or two he's
gonna take in a different direction he's
gonna see something that's what I see I
think his he's got Woody Allen type
right right without the [ __ ] door you
know the daughter give some shoutouts
real quick here come on man kevin
harvick
super fan Alex Ramirez is okay Louie the
kid always
Manny kotas Damian and then dad
Keagan hapa Jairo Miskin Rybak Mike
right Mike right back you know I love
you I can't see what might out with my
regular butt and the church leader mr.
Scott Cunningham always running [ __ ]
over there online letting [ __ ] know
what time it is but no that was uh I I
it's it people have to see if you're in
a rush with anything all right it's that
just stand up I love I love I love
watching fly-by-night people in my 27
years ago I seen so many fly-by-night
people right and what people don't
understand today is I've seen so many I
mean I've been exposed to so many
fly-by-night people that you know the
the symptoms right you know the opening
ones you know the symptoms you know we
get approached three times a week for
something I can approach twenty times a
week for something and I know the
wording I know the you know already
yeah yeah yeah you've been here and you
it's weird that sometimes I [ __ ] with
them and let them play that game I'd let
them think yeah no worries
they don't even know how to handle it
because they didn't prepare for that
they were prepared for getting shut down
I threw that game completely the [ __ ]
off you Sam yeah yeah yeah we've seen
I've seen so many shysters like Lee told
me that he was thinking about going to
work for a service that they offered
that they departed they bought the
content from the stand up and they put
on a site and people click you know I've
heard right in 20 and then 20 years in
LA we've heard every scam right right
you young comics that think you're
worrying I smile if you don't have the
dedication yeah just talked about one
mr. Cummings here and it's smell yeah
yeah yeah I smell it on people yeah you
know I paid names you i bait you I let
you think that you
right I know who's doing their homework
right because you did the homework yeah
so you know when the homework has been
done right right teen years is [ __ ]
you know it's in your blood at that
point I mean doing comedy 20 70 yeah so
18 years for me was 91 so I was 2001 and
then plus eight is what thousand nine
that's when I started coming into my own
yeah eighteen years whatever I started
taking a gamble on storytelling I had
done it before yeah but I wasn't sure
about it then I'm Irish if he opened up
the door a little bit yeah and yeah I
listened to a Showtime special that
Whitney Cummings had done not Whitney
Whitney Cummings and produced where she
introduced a bunch of college okay and
one night I went into my bathroom I was
taking a [ __ ] I left the volume up yeah
and I heard this comic without watching
him I heard his material right and by
hearing his material I realized how bad
I was because he was just doing wall
liners and they're funny and they take
you to a certain distance in comedy
right but after a certain point those
one-liners joined up the trouble runs
the rest of your life yeah there's very
few like that the Hedberg type and stuff
like that no Shaffir changed me to man
one of the first storytelling show guys
before were long before was a gym show
at the lab with Eddie Pepitone and it
was a revenge theme and that one show
changed my comedy trajectory because my
first two albums are more joke based and
then I did this story about [ __ ]
well [ __ ] with these dishwashers in
college like just doing this ridiculous
prank that I would I would do these
crazy print but this went on for like
like four months this crazy prank it was
a [ __ ] horrible how far I push these
people but I did the revenge story was
I'm like my theme was or basis the story
was I'm like ah this guy should [ __ ]
get me like I'm the one who deserves to
have revenge like I [ __ ] with a
stranger horrific ly for like Elmo's
happy but then I started telling that on
the road afterwards and I liked it so
much more than the rest of my materials
were just his real [ __ ] there was
interesting national issue it
you changed all the future albums had
changed my whole career completely
because the first time I story told on
stage was at the belly room
I caught Mitzi on a night of yeah this
is I know bitsy can I do stories from a
Cuban street Wow I had a show called
stories come to Cuba's yeah
it had to be 1990 and I was into the
comedy in seven years yeah and I was
basically doing one-liners like Rodney
and trying to be cued up on stage of
dirty jokes and I took that upstairs and
it changed my [ __ ] life forever yeah
cuz I stayed on stage for two hours
just tone stories about my childhood
right was the first time I saw people's
jaw drops riveting a real story forever
laughs I saw people cry yeah it was
[ __ ] amazing when I when I got really
high that night because I had taken
myself yeah to a complete different
level I had forced my hand
yeah like this was way out of who the
[ __ ] I was like if I was only supposed
to fight yeah I was only prepared for
three rounds of fighting right I fought
he just have them round yeah yeah and
unprepared right which really takes
ganas which mentally take a somewhere
else
yeah which and I still would store it I
still was [ __ ] petrified right
because it is scary it's a [ __ ] scary
at first when you talk about like I just
did I did some little Oh to get people
to kind of join this little part of the
podcast I have I did like a an album
that you got when you signed up for this
like bonus content print a premium thing
but it was like I did two albums that
record in one weekend it like did one
album Friday night one album Saturn I
just recorded two different sets and I
didn't even realize how long it was but
I can't imagine at the beginning there's
one bit I have it's 15 minutes long and
it's just one story which for me like in
the beginning there's no [ __ ] way
because [ __ ] what I liked about short
jokes early on was it's a confidence
thing got you there to the point and if
you gotta laugh yeah you got out of the
woods quickly yeah and if it doesn't
work on your next Joe 30 seconds when
you do a story this 15 [ __ ] minutes
long and you set it up and you know the
payoff doesn't come to real health and
you think 40 minutes you can't bail and
that commitment freaks people the [ __ ]
out when they're starting because
they're like
[ __ ] what if what if they don't like it
and it's like but yeah you just have to
reach this point where you're almost so
broken in a way that you don't give a
[ __ ] what they like you you're just
willing to push what you like on them
and you and you have to be okay with it
not working and just and that's and
that's fine it'll be and ironically that
makes it work so much better you know my
first two years of comedy all I did was
race to the light yeah yeah I played
race to the light yeah you walk up a
quote I would not shut up until the
[ __ ] light turned and then I'd run
out of there like a [ __ ] felon being
chased [ __ ] by 20 cops
it was the club owners ago guy you got
to slow down right because it was just I
just wanted to get a laugh yeah I want
to quickly go away and if you keep
talking you can't hear the silent long
petrify the silence is beginning right
and the bombings like at the early
bombings I had take a bombing got a
[ __ ] private function I some guy saw
me at the New York Comedy Club and he's
like what do you charges in 15 right he
goes come to this address on 7 and I
went up there there's no microphone yeah
I was not prepared right whatsoever I
was doing comedy two years yeah today I
would have crushed that right from the
top of a rock I would've got up then
done my material yelling and I will bang
them up for [ __ ] ten GS oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah like a savage I would have had the
bikini tops up it would have been crazy
the old man I would have him good I did
not know how to control an audience we
got 30 feet away without a microphone
right if I was in between a pool and
them and they were all drinking
champagne huh and I'm sitting there with
no microphone you forget we don't
prepares your horse
Joe yeah let me know without that with
this is interesting though the journey
of it works like I've gotten into that
now it's like without all those lessons
and stuff like it's funny what brings
you somebody just asked me when I did
that little live podcast last week they
did a little questions and somebody was
like what made you think of time stuff
what made you want to do this and I just
in a moment of like just well just being
honest whatever I go failure I go years
and years of failure
I created time suck you know it's just
cuz you've learned but then you learn
from all those failed and had I not had
all those failures I wouldn't be able to
pull off you know like I do like a times
I guess like an hour and a half with no
no guests there's no way I could have
done that and kept it interesting we
have without so we come so many years of
[ __ ] up and making horrible decisions
about learning and learning and learning
and learning and then it's a yeah yeah
it is you know what this doesn't just
pertain to Connolly oh yeah I guess yes
it's like in any art that you [ __ ]
choose like yeah you know I see now
repeated this a thousand times I hate
that they make you make a pick a major
when you're 18 that's not all right you
don't know what the [ __ ] you want to do
you just hear what they're your stupid
[ __ ] friends say at Starbucks right
right repeat what the [ __ ] they say yeah
it's reactin and we're gonna tell your
father bad news and you want to be a
chef and [ __ ] money on it
you're gonna go [ __ ] play the drums
play no it's a horror show
right it's killed more people and
anything because making bad choices yeah
yeah it's all a part of this [ __ ]
journey right to get good at something
you gotta do you gotta make bad [ __ ]
choices yeah and you know what really
hurts when they hurt your pocket oh yeah
that's when you really learn a lesson
it's like when you know oh my girlfriend
left me cuz I don't play the flute that
some guy might be a girl from left in
this still 22g good but that's two
different [ __ ] lessons you know oh
yeah
I'm just motivation especially like I
got two kids and stuff now but when you
know I remember like ah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah man those drama you know the
podcast tonight oh yeah yep it's a
[ __ ] back room of a mansion that you
bought from their $25,000 you got a pool
you got a [ __ ] door man they make
yeah the Mexican name that says I love
America on nobody knows the world you
look like a [ __ ] King I mean we I
mean we live good up there and seven now
but it's like but it is crazy like they
talked about some financial motivation
you know and like when you had those
moments I mean count I remember read
this book early on is David Mamet some
playwrights
I'm sure theater people are like oh [ __ ]
if David Mamet how do you know but he
wrote some book about truth and lies
something who's for actors but one of
the main piece of advice I took from
that he go
the paraphrasing don't give yourself an
out don't give yourself a back-up plan
because if you do you'll take it because
this business is so [ __ ] rough and I
thought about that like I remember
thinking like you know if I woulda had
an out you know six years ago I had
things were just a low point and taurine
and stuff to kids you know like money in
the bank was almost gone
calendar was looking [ __ ] interrupt
you yeah I want you to close your eyes
and honestly tell me I'll give you one
minute give me a number of how many
comics could have been stars that you
personally know if they would have given
up their day job how many people would
have been stars if they were to get out
the day job yeah I know three of them
right now but if they would have taken a
chance and really believed in who the
[ __ ] they were it was a male on TV right
now in some sorta way I'm not saying
there would have been a star I know
three people right now who are that
funny
yeah we'll continue to have it and it's
the biggest fear that you can have is
that safety net there's one name that
keeps dominating I mean I won't say but
yeah he had a financial advisor job
humbly numbers how many people do you
know that you feel in your heart if they
gave up their day job would be making a
living today in Los Angeles I could name
just based on talent just based on re
talent that I [ __ ] respect right but I
would go [ __ ] I wish I had that specific
gift I wish I could write like that I
write I had that I for ya
this I got two of my head to my head
yeah like I yeah I know them gastly and
I will punch him right in the [ __ ]
mouth but right they always thought that
that they always thought that insurance
yeah was the key to their and they yep
you don't understand that if you don't
cut that out of your life that oh yeah
umbilical cord oh man
it's nothing motivates you like fear for
lease nothing motivates me like fear
when I'm like how the [ __ ] yeah you do
your best work my gonna help you in the
chorus yep
you know if I put you in a corner and I
put a knife to your throat right you do
your best work oh yeah you're actually
you're gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that's when
because Julie no problem agai you're
[ __ ] you know you're doing elbows your
cousins were teaching over here
throw in striking out oh my god yeah
yeah you know your best work right when
you're sitting there smoking cigarettes
and somebody's rubbing your feet
yeah you do your best work when yeah we
don't stream do your best work
but you don't want to hear Joey Diaz or
your father or your mother or Kisha
right say I told you so right oh oh
that's what that one that makes my dick
hard for sure that's the one will okay
yeah I don't even say how do you have
apply to you I don't even reply to you I
just make a mental note and I keep it in
my ass the weirdest [ __ ] thing and it
happened you keep mentioning the podcast
yeah happen with this it happened with
the original podcast can now with Lee
it's happened with ten years ago the
right people that are talking to me yeah
wouldn't even let me in their room right
right right they would ask Rogan why
would they bring being re disgusting
animals now and now look at the two of
you square business yeah and I remember
hearing all those negative comments now
I could be again you know the ad
danghang for some beef with a woman
online and then she revealed that ship
been raped twice and died and I go
listen I understand the anger in your
heart but until you lose an anger you
never move forward in this life I was
hanging at the world to it God took my
mother I thought there was no more gun I
had that chip on my shoulder for 20
years I didn't even yeah funny so I lost
that anger Wow nobody factors that we
put in our lives
anger every fear yeah that once you go
away from that [ __ ] you just go you know
what done I'm going to sleep I'm going
to [ __ ] sleep it's over you're not
gonna [ __ ] with me no more because
that's gonna get up at night when you're
talking when you turn in and you're
going up and you're smoking cigarettes
yeah you're speaking to me right now
oh no no it's horrible something I'm
getting some more horrible when you [ __ ]
yeah take that chance off the cliffs
yeah you're like I'm gone brother John
but and
eighteen years in I still fight it I
still found get I love it I'm getting
some more Oh some like a new ink or
whatever like that in a few weeks and
I've won this tattoo forever and fear is
your only guts rage against machinery
but I'm having like that big with some
imagery and stuff put on one of my arms
because I'm like I have to still fight
that to this day to take new chances and
it's like I'll feel that like now people
aren't gonna like no I can't like I said
I'll still fight kind of betting on
myself you know like that just cuz it
but but then I always you know in the
end I'll take that chance but it's like
yeah man yeah you have to get out of
your own way it's so [ __ ] hard in
this business sometimes because yeah
yeah do what it looks like in general
life in general yet now this business I
guess yeah you got to come on I know
that you requested to come out a few
times I already have guessed this [ __ ]
and we will funky with Wednesday's but
I'm happy I got the gout so thankful
yeah you had me out well you know like
more people you know you were embraer
this weekend yeah osterholm yep
you're not doing anything swinging my
brain it's a great [ __ ] Club yeah I
think he's got shows Thursday Friday
Saturday to show Sunday oh just one show
Sunday oh but but yeah show something go
see the podcast is there it's time suck
and it's just uh they finally they can
find it there's an app there's a time
suck app but it's on you know iTunes
Google Play all that and it's just one
subject each week while they're released
one a week serial killer historical
figure it's all the same kind of
research you would get in an academic
podcast but it's more like every person
language it's like you know I'm gonna
fair amount of profanity I'm gonna throw
in some jokes and try to make it [ __ ]
interesting for someone who might fall
asleep during a normal lecture that's
how I am that's it there's that what do
you got planned this weekend at Todd's
you got some gigs yeah I'm supposed sure
you're going up against my man up in
Santa Barbara
people have to make a decision now do we
go see [ __ ] st. [ __ ] my man Dan
Cummings or do I see Lisa at in Santa
Barbara
it is both his both here this boat
absolutely I go see Dan I'm gonna be at
the Velvet Jones with Sam Tripoli Mike
Catherwood and Mike Tully and then I
think tomorrow night depending on what
happens there's a chance I might be on
the Queen Mary in Long Beach with
D'Agostino sorta and Steve Simone look
at you know you go you're going I love
good okay you're good you got clearance
everything is good
I'm happy you got to come on here huh me
like I said Nayak is sold out now you
got April [ __ ] 4th and 5th at Santa
Fe casino in Albuquerque and don't
forget for 15-20 in Columbus Ohio with
cake cream quickly on the [ __ ]
druggies who's better than you [ __ ]
thank you for the love and support all
week you know I love you [ __ ]
with all my heart I want to thank Dan
Cummings I want to thank my main man
Lisa at and I also want to thank me
undies listen let me tell you something
everybody always complains I can't find
a date I can't let you want to look good
you gotta wear the right underwear
checkout me on these matching pairs a
unique fun gift for you and your little
sweetheart
their perfect balance a comfortable fit
and they come an exciting Prince don't
spend another weekend giving out the
same gifts checkout me on these calm and
find the best match for your match you
understand me listen me undies is the
most comfortable and fun of these you
and your significant other will have a
home alright matching pairs are fun that
thoughtful and that comfortable gift
when you share them with that person
listen to me on these are made from the
softest materials on earth we're talking
three times softer than cotton so right
now the undies has an exclusive often a
an offer I'm sorry I got a [ __ ]
cottonmouth I smoked some reefing means
well beyond these has an exclusive off
of my listeners and for first-time
purchases when you go to be on these
comm /jo what they gonna do is I'm sorry
I'm [ __ ] all [ __ ] up here me undies
are so sure they'll be underwear they're
gonna offer you on a percent money-back
guarantee 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you don't love the first pair they'll
refund them full nope it's a no-brainer
you got 20% off underwear and 100%
satisfaction guarantee
what the hell are you waiting for me
undies I work in jiu-jitsu and it's not
my exercise they keep that area and draw
nice and dry with no problem all right
and right now you're gonna get 20% off a
pair of me on these Plus free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee go to
beyond these calm / Joey
that's me undies doctor / Joey and again
listen everybody's trying to save money
and do this and that especially when it
comes to you as far as I'm concerned
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country you know why they offer a
two-person plan they offer a family meal
plan and in my book a family that cooks
together stays together
blue apron is the leading meal kit
delivery service in the US and what many
people know this a lot of people don't
know and they don't know what type of
meals you get when you cook with blue
apron you're just not gonna have burgers
for dinner you're gonna be making short
rib burgers with hot cheddar sauce on a
pretzel bun you gonna be making seared
steaks with thyme pan sauce and mashed
potatoes with green beans and crispy
shallots all in under 45 minutes and
without a trip to the grocery store you
go in Joey what are you a [ __ ]
magician no I'm not a magician
that's what blue apron does Lee Lee
lives off blue apron probably I love it
my next box is coming with three amazing
dishes that has Italian style shrimp and
sweet peppers
I have quick bucatini and I have
pan-fried chicken with zucchini and
pickled peppers it's gonna be amazing
this is what I'm letting you do blue
apron lets you see the power and what
foo can do blue apron delivers fresh pre
proportion ingredients with step-by-step
recipes right to your goddamn door that
can be cooked under 45 minutes the menu
changes every week based on what's in
season and what's designed by blue apron
and their in-house culinary dream boy
print offers 12 new recipes each week
and customers can pick two three or four
recipes best on what fits their schedule
not only that boy presents only non GMO
ingredients and meat with no added
hormones who's better than blue apron
nobody listen we want you to hear about
food you love to cook and eat we all eat
dinner but we believe with Boyd when we
make incredible home cooking accessible
for any night of the week
so right now today blue apron is
treating the church family that
hours off your first order when you
visit boyfriend dot-com / Joey you like
Joey that deal it's too good to be true
Joan how can you be giving me down on
Wednesday why you want to me like this
listen what uncle Joey lie to you look
at the menu this week you got pan-fried
chicken breast with a sweet tangy
zucchini oh you got parmesan crusted
states with mashed potatoes and broccoli
you got a quick bucatini with broccoli
and pecorino cheese are you kidding me
or what
where you gonna get that type action
nowhere blueprint calm / Joey blue apron
dot-com / Joey get $30 off your blue
apron right now by going to blue apron
calm / Joey blue apron a better way to
cook I want to thank my man Dan the
[ __ ] truck Cummings I want to thank
my little flying Jew over there the
original [ __ ] lee-sia
I want to thank my girl TC for a couple
of visiting us and welcome in without
[ __ ] them beauty I gotta take them a
look offer and [ __ ] that said I love
you [ __ ] don't forget I'll see
you [ __ ] at NIACC or Santa Fe
April 4th and 5th don't forget to stop
by and see Dan Cummings and don't forget
that go give Lee ugh the rest of your
[ __ ] get ready for next week
with ro and he that [ __ ]
stay black have a great [ __ ] weekend
and uncle Joey loves you take that
[ __ ] meal Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]